and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber and thanks for
joining us the lead agent in the Pike
County Massacre returns to the stand to
testify about recreating the so-called
murder truck used by the Wagners and how
he believes movies played a role in The
Murders long crime Zone and Jeanette
Levy's here with what the jury heard and
what they saw
well Jesse prosecutors are wrapping up
their case against George Wagner IV and
they're hoping to eliminate doubt in the
minds of jurors that he took part in the
rodent and Gilly murders
BCI agents recreated a false bed in the
truck Jake Wagner said he his father and
older brother drove the night of the
murders Jake Wagner testified he built
that false bed and put bales of either
hay or straw on top of it so he and
George Wagner IV had a place to hide as
they approached the first crime scene
but George Wagner the force lawyers have
suggested he would have been too big in
2016 to fit under that false bed so lead
BCI agent Ryan scheiderer showed photos
of two large detectives fitting in the
truck bed without issue Wagner the force
lawyers questioned the Reconstruction
did you place a dozen bales of hay on
top of this piece of plywood like Jake
testify
I did not prosecutors also offered
additional evidence about The Boondock
Saints movies
Jake Wagner had testified he watched the
ding dong clip to psych himself up the
night of the murders but now prosecutors
say the movie is even more relevant
because they believe Jake and George
Wagner copied the twin brothers in the
movie down to what they wore the night
of the murders and the weapons used with
the two brothers wearing the masks
with pistols
Maglite suppressors right before they
kill some people but George Wagner's
attorneys are questioning whether the
movie Bears any real similarities to the
Rhoden and Gilly murders it's either
movie involve a mother figure or wrongly
believes her granddaughter under the age
of two has been sexually assaulted no
now that last question actually
referenced Angela Wagner the mother of
both George Wagner IV and Jake Wagner
who said that when she was on the
witness stand she said they planned and
carried out these murders because they
felt they needed to protect the daughter
that Jake Wagner shared with victim
Hannah Mae Rhoden and on
cross-examination special agent cider
scheiderer conceded that there was
really no evidence that this little girl
had been molested only that the family
feared it could possibly happen Jesse
thanks Anjanette great reporting as
always I'm joined right now by my
co-host Terry Austin and criminal
defense attorney Casey early it's great
to have you both here Casey I'll start
with you you know this trial has been
going on for months and I have to Wonder
Isn't it having some impact on the legal
teams and as well as the jury I mean
imagine sitting on this case
well it definitely has some form of
impact I've been a child for a week and
then I've been in trial for weeks so we
have to understand that the jury they
have a life outside of the Court they
have children they have their careers so
after a while it can become very
stressful to come into court listen to
the evidence day after day but I'm
pretty sure that this jury was vetted
properly and that they are listening to
the evidence in order to make a judgment
a verdict for or uh against the
defendant I'm also not surprised that
it's taking this long it's such a
complex case and speaking which Terry
you know the prosecutions focused on
these similarities between The Boondock
Saints movies and the actual murders I
haven't heard of that before you think
that's a good strategy you know it's not
a good strategy listen I understand that
the brothers they looked at the movies
and I guess they wanted to copy the
characters but they were doing that
essentially just to get up their nerve
to get motivated I don't think that they
were literally following the movie's
plot and that's the problem with the
prosecution relying so much on the plot
if there are inconsistencies and
apparently there are inconsistencies the
jury might think that there is some
doubt there so I think that they should
just move on and not focus so much on
what's going on in the movies and focus
more on what's happening in front of
them a scary imitation art imitating
life in a way a really scary there